g'day everyone my name's lucas and this
is some sub a channel about survival in
the online jungle now you might be
surprised to see me again and asking
yourself where's the lovely emily or the
swag bradley well i'm just here to
provide a little drop of aussie in this
otherwise posh british ocean how's that
for you on the topic of british people
and their strange shenanigans have you
ever dreamt of owning your own
invisibility cloak from harry potter
my body's gone well now engineers around
the world are working on similar devices
but the results are far from convincing
the main problem is that such an
illusion should combine sort of two
contradictory principles for
invisibility to work it needs to let in
light from objects outside of itself
but not let light through in the
opposite direction
in other words you see everything and
nobody sees you
i've got good news for you this is
possible in the world of computer
technology
and today we're going to be opening the
pandora's box of digital invisibility to
show you how to put such device on your
computer by the way
the computer i'm talking about has been
in front of you this whole time
well this is it this is no simple flash
drive it already has a powerful
operating system installed on it that
will work with most personal computers
and laptops just insert it into the usb
port and reboot the system to open up a
whole new world of possibilities
finish working turn off the computer
pull out the flash drive and no trace of
your actions will remain
if you're interested in information
security or maybe just a keen television
fan you've probably heard about the
series mr robot
just a few years ago it really raised
the bar for authenticity of representing
hacking and television shows the
protagonist didn't try to hack the
pentagon by stuffing meaningless
combinations of characters into a
command line or you know frantically
typing gibberish on their keyboards they
used real network monitoring programs
port scanners and similar tools
it was thanks to mr robot that many
enthusiasts learned about kali linux
kali is based on devon but diff is in
the focus of the programs that are
included in the build for example
there's wireshark here a network packet
analyzer that we used in a video about
how phones are listening to us there's
the famous network scanner and map
the legendary john the ripper password
cracker
tools for working with my favorite
arduino boards and even multegro in case
you have to make use of open source
intelligence
this distribution was originally created
for specialists in the field of computer
security but its increasing popularity
has led to it acquiring a large number
of interesting modules and programs
of course they allow you to not only
monitor other computers but also to
fully control your own
therefore kali linux is ideally suited
for the role of our invisible computer
so i'm not going to install cali on my
computer but instead i'm going to make a
bootable usb flash drive
firstly this means i won't leave any
traces of my presence on the computer
itself
secondly there will also be no evidence
left on the flash drive either
each time the power is turned off the
system will return to its original
settings
nice i'm going to show you how to do
this step by step
this is the simplest and most logical
step i go to the sidekali.org and i find
myself facing a choice
here you can download versions of the
operating system for windows mac mobile
devices and even single bought computers
like raspberry pi
if you don't have a spare usb flash
drive at hand just simply download
images for virtual machines it's not
going to have the sort of full
functionality and furthermore shouldn't
be used if you are trying to achieve
anonymity but it'll do the trick if you
just want to feel like elliot anderson
right now what interests me the most is
the live boot section
here are the system assemblies that can
be run from a usb flash drive one click
and the download of three gigabytes has
begun
i don't recommend downloading the full
version it's probably going to be too
big and if something is missing in the
future you can always install
applications with a couple of commands
in the console
don't download the experimental version
either this is pretty much just for
experts and enthusiasts to look at
errors in the code
i mean we're nerding out here today but
come on we're not experimental mode
nerding out just yet pay attention to
the link titled documentation you know
we're embarking on the path of real
hackers so we're gonna have to read up a
little bit of the background you see the
whole process of creating a bootable usb
flash drive is described here in detail
there are links to programs for
recording images and choosing the
necessary settings
i will use the first of the other
proposed programs etcha
there are only two buttons first i need
to select the image that i'll upload to
the flash drive
and then specify its ladder that's all
nothing complicated or unnecessary the
installation process takes about 10
minutes and during this process there
isn't really much to look at but after
it's all over the installer will invite
you to leave your opinion about the
program on twitter i haven't even
launched cali yet but i can already
boast that i'm a hacker
excellent
so windows no longer sees the flash
drive this is a good sign it means
everything is working as it should i'll
leave it in the computer and restart the
system i have priority booting now
configured from usb devices so the
computer will first try to find the
operating system on external hard drives
and flash drives and only then from the
main disk
so now cali boot menu appears on my
screen
i'll probably have to come back later to
the advanced settings to check a few
things but right now i'm pretty keen to
get started let's click on the top line
okay
so here's my first question the
password's already been set but i don't
know it
okay well i'll start by trying the
classics username admin password admin
wait a minute
not gonna work this is linux so it
should be maybe root and root
aha okay reject it again well we'll have
to check the documentation section it
turns out that i almost guessed it i
mean previously by default all users
worked in cali under the main user but
recently the creators of the system
decided to change this pair too
and here's another excellent example of
programmers creativity
cali and cali
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's it i'm in the system
so far nothing abnormal except you can
see that the start button is in the
upper left hand corner a little unusual
but you'll forget about it pretty quick
the list of programs is huge and the
names of the sections alone command
respect
see information gathering vulnerability
analysis web application analysis
password selection attacks on wireless
networks well admit it your eyes lit up
at that one too even the browser is
putting ideas in my head i mean look at
the bookmarks that are already saved
here
using this system as an average office
computer is unlikely to be comfortable
there's a text editor but it's very
simple very rough it's enough for notes
maybe drafts you'd pretty much be
struggling to create a beautiful report
in it and besides when i turn off the
computer
all the information and settings will
disappear
the next time the system will boot it'll
do so in exactly the same state it was
during its first launch if an attacker
tries to steal your laptop it's enough
to just pull out the flash drive and
they won't get any information of course
you can allocate an additional section
for storing data
but what we want to build here is a tool
that leaves no trace so in this instance
we're not going to do that if you decide
to save the data create an encrypted
disk it has a unique feature where you
can set a password that will not open it
but instead erase the keys and the
encrypted data i recommend using long
and random passwords to store your data
and making the destruction password
short and predictable for example using
your date of birth or the name of your
pet
if someone tries to open the protection
they'll start probably by going through
those obvious passwords and thereby
destroying any evidence against you as
for the data security on the computer
itself it's quite incomparable with
windows
so now let's try to assess what other
hackers can find out about us
i'll start with digital fingerprints
which we've already talked about in a
separate video
the result of the check on am i unique
website
leaves a lot to be desired despite the
fact that i'm using the same version of
the system as thousands of other people
there are things giving me away
look first of all there's the firefox
version why are we still here
just to suffer
plus the size of my laptop screen is
also giving me away fortunately i just
need this browser to download another
one that can mimic other people's
fingerprints
such solutions are often used by traffic
arbitrage specialists advertisers and
contextual advertising experts now i
won't advertise the specific solution
but i'll just say that my choice would
be between commercial solutions such as
multi-login or ghost browser they will
reliably cover my digital fingerprints
and they're enough to protect my privacy
during normal surfing now the result on
am i unique looks completely different
of course i won't connect as well to a
network directly i'll take the
opportunity to connect to a list of
proxy servers
this is much easier to do here than in
other operating systems i mean have you
ever tried to set up a wired network in
windows it's just a pile of menus some
of which are going back to the days of
xp here everything is intuitive and
clearly organized
obviously i won't connect to the
internet via office or home wi-fi
for now other people's networks will
become my allies
fortunately i can connect with them even
without knowing their passwords you see
kali linux already has programs
installed for hacking other people's
networks by the way for working in
public places the creators of cali have
provided quite a fun function
look here now we'll type the command in
the terminal
and the interface will change you see
the formidable kali linux has disguised
itself as the usual windows 10. now you
can sit quietly in the food court
drinking a bubble tea and no one will
pay much attention to you
[Music]
you know i myself didn't expect that in
under 40 minutes i would be able to
create a flash drive that would turn an
ordinary computer into a powerful tool
for defense or attack
the tools of network security experts
are becoming more and more accessible
every day
if 10 years ago we pretty much couldn't
even get past the black screen of the
terminal
now there are more and more tools with
increasingly simple and friendly
interfaces
don't be afraid to jump head first into
the world of network security even with
just a little bit of effort you can
significantly protect yourself from
intruders
in the digital jungle the weak get got
so even if you spend a small amount of
time on such security measures you'll be
of no interest to those lurking in the
shadows
feel free to leave questions about
information security in the comments
share your experiences with us and tell
us what you would like to discuss next
all the presenters including myself
closely follow the comments
my name's lucas good luck getting online
with cali and free booting your
neighbor's internet
i and the some sub experts will be
waiting for you in our next video see
you next time
[Music]
you